So in the last video we created a door blueprint, and we've connected up the E button to an event.
Now we're going to connect this event to opening and closing the door. So back to the blueprint here.
I'm gonna leave the print string here just so that we know that this is running, in case we need to debug anything.
Now
The first thing that I'm going to connect after this, is I'm going to drag off, and I'm going to search for a flip-flop node.
Now the flip-flop node is a flow control node, and what it's going to do is, the first time that we execute this,
it's going to do whatever is attached to the A. And the second time we do it, it's going to do whatever is attached to the B.
And then the third time, it's going to go back to A, and it will alternate between the two different options.
Meaning we can toggle something on and off. We will use it in this instance to open and close the door.
Now, after the flip-flop node, we're going to pull off, and search for something that's called a timeline.
On this timeline, we're going to rename to be open slash close door.
Now the first flip-flop is set to play. What I want to do, is I want to connect the second one to reverse.
Now, how a timeline works, is this is going to run for the one we push play.
The timeline is going to run for however long we set it off for.
And whenever we push reverse, it will reverse from the point that it is to the beginning.
So the play is going to exit play forward, and reverse will reverse.
Now, we're not using the play from start or reverse from the end. So this means if we would
hit this up halfway through, or we'd stop it for some reason, it will pick up where it's left off.
Now, on the output pins for the timeline, you can see we have an update and a finish.
Now, what a timeline will do, is whilst this is be playing and updating,
it will trigger anything which is connected to the update pin on every frame of the game.
So effectively on tick. What we're going to do, is we're going to use this to animate and rotate
the door out. And when it's finished, it will execute anything that's attached to the finished
sign. But we need to set up some kind of output variables from this.
So double-click on the timeline to open it up,
and you're going to see that we get a page which looks a little bit like this.
At the moment, the timeline is set to go on for five seconds. This is too long. We don't
want the door to take five seconds to open. So let's change this to one second.
Now, next to this, we have a plus track. If I click on the plus track, you can see
I have five options. Now, we're going to use the add float track, because we don't
need anything more complicated. And that's going to create a new track that looks like this.
And I'm going to call this door open alpha. Now, all we want to do is we want to return a value
between zero and one. And these values are going to determine how open the door is,
with zero being completely closed and one being completely open. And over the one second,
it is going to return different values, depending on how far through, in order for us to open the
door. So let's add in some values. So place your cursor as close to zero zero as possible,
double-click, right-hand click, and select add key to curve float zero. And up here,
I'm just going to make sure we've got absolutely zero zero. And now you can see that we have one
key. And now I'm going to come up to the top right-hand corner. So that's one second.
And I am going to add a curve. I've added a key there. Now, this is too low. What I want is I
want the time to be one and the value to be one. Now, as you can see, this has now
gone off the charts, and we can't see what it looks like. However, if I press the zoom to fit,
we now get a better idea. But the way that the timeline is going to work is it's going to return
a value to the update for every interval of time that it is pinned. So if the update happens
zero, it will return the value zero. However, if the update happens 0.25
seconds since the timeline has started, it will return 0.25. And the same for 0.5.
And in the end, when it finishes, it will return the value one. This is going to, on each tick,
return a different value. They've got a very simple line here, but if it was slightly more
complicated, then we could get more values out of that. Now, I will now come back to the
event graph, and you'll see that a new output pin has appeared on the right-hand side of the
open to close, and that is the door open alpha. Now, if I move to the right, what I want to do
is I want to grab the door mesh, and I'm going to pull in a reference to that.
So we have a reference to the door mesh, and I'm going to drag off, and I'm going to type in
set relative rotation. Now, if I drag out and connect that up to the update,
this is going to allow us to set the rotation of the door. Now, I don't know what rotations
I want yet. To start with, I'm probably going to stick with zero, zero, zero, but I don't know
what I'm going to rotate to. But that doesn't matter too much because I'm using an alpha.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag off of the new rotator, and I'm going to type in
lerp. And there is an option for lerp rotator. Now, what the lerp is, is it is a shortening
turn for a linear interpolate. And what a linear interpolate would do is when this value
is zero, it will provide you, it will provide the result of A. When this alpha is one, it will
provide you the result of B. And when it is 0.5, it will return you halfway between
these two values. And this is really useful for us to use in combination with an alpha.
So if I pull out in the alpha here, and if I change A, we're fine with it being zero, zero, zero.
So I'm going to need to figure out what rotation I need here at the end.
So in order to do that, I'm going to jump back to the viewport. I'm going to grab the door.
I'm just going to rotate it out. I think about 90 degrees is good. So I know that my rotation
that I want to get to is zero, zero, 90. I'll reset this back to the default.
And I'm going to jump back into the event graph. I'm just going to put 90 here.
So what this does now is it's going to use the timeline's alpha on the lerp to set the
relative rotation of just the component, the door mesh. And it will either play this from
the beginning or from the other flip flop. It's going to reverse it back.
So we're playing this timeline forwards and backwards. Let's test this out.
Now if I walk up to the door and press E, we can see that it opens. If I press E again,
you can see that we are playing that timeline backwards and forwards over one second.
Right. So we now have the functionality for the door to open and close.
What I want to do next is we're going to look at locking this.